continuamos con nuestro ejemplo de la
producción de jugo de naranja y en esta
ocasión quiero que pensemos cuál sería
la cantidad racional de jugo de naranja
que deberíamos producir dado nuestro
precio del mercado vamos a imaginar que
nuestro precio de mercado ahora en el
jugo de naranja es de 50 centavos el
galón y voy a asumir que hay muchos
productores aquí vamos a tener que
adecuarnos al precio establecido no
podemos cobrar lo que quisiéramos por
galón ya que si cobramos aunque sea un
sentaba por encima de este precio la
gente irá a comprar su jugo de naranja
con otros proveedores así que este es el
precio que podemos cobrar 50 centavos
por galón si pensamos esto en términos
de ingresos marginales por galón
incremental ese primer incremento en
galón pasará de 50 centavos el siguiente
incremento en galón también nos costará
50 centavos y el siguiente también 50
centavos el galón así que durante los
primeros 1000 galones obtendremos 50
centavos por cada uno de esos galones y
para los primeros 10.000 galones igual
recibiremos 50 centavos por galón
nuestra curva de ingresos marginales va
y así una línea recta que se mantiene a
los 50 centavos por galón este es
nuestro margen de ingresos a 50 centavos
el galón ahora en esta situación cuál es
la cantidad razonable de galones de jugo
que yo debo producir
para mantener ganancias y bueno aquí hay
dos elementos uno es producir todo lo
que podamos tanto como sea posible por
lo que podamos distribuir nuestros
costos fijos en todos esos galones para
distribuir nuestro costo fijo esa es una
manera de pensar en ello otra forma es
que bueno tenemos cierta cantidad de
costos fijos vamos a gastar mil dólares
sin importar qué ocurre pues por qué no
tratamos de obtener la mayor cantidad de
ingresos posibles para poder compensar
estos costos fijos pensamos en ello en
términos del promedio del costo fijo
mientras mayor cantidad produzcamos el
componente del costo para ello de los
costos fijos va a ir disminuyendo cada
vez más así que queremos distribuir lo
más posible nuestro costo fijo
en lo que tenemos que pensar
especialmente si queremos superar este
bache en la curva de costo marginal en
donde al producir más unidades este
costo marginal va a ir aumentando
no queremos llegar a producir tantos
galones que el costo marginal de esa
unidad incremental sea mayor que el
costo marginal o que el costo marginal
de esa unidad incremental sea mayor que
el ingreso marginal de venderla
así que hasta que hasta qué
y el ingreso marginal sea igual que el
costo marginal otra forma de decirlo es
que no queremos no queremos que el costo
marginal y esto es cuando superamos este
bache de acá donde queremos producir lo
más posible y los a costo marginal va a
ir aumentando y aumentando no queremos
llegar a producir tanto como acá porque
aquí el costo para producir esos galones
es mayor de la que vamos a obtener al
vender esos galones a lo mejor aquí el
galón extra me cuesta 53 centavos
mientras que sólo lo puedo vender a 50
centavos así que cada galón exa que
producimos aquí va a hacer que perdamos
dinero por lo que no queremos que
nuestro costo marginal sea mayor que en
nuestro ingreso marginal cuando vemos
este tipo de gráfica tiene sentido ver
que bueno nuestro ingreso marginal es
igual a nuestro costo marginal y esta es
la cantidad racional a producir que son
9 mil galones de jugo
así que vamos a estar en esta línea
vamos a producir nueve mil galones el
ingreso que vamos a obtener va a ser el
área del rectángulo que es tan alto como
el precio que vamos a obtener al vender
esto
multiplicado por el número de unidades
este va a ser el ingreso total que bueno
los hombre haría pero va a ser que se
complique más esta gráfica
y cuál es nuestro costo total bueno
tenemos nuestro costo total promedio
aquí esto es nuestro costo total
promedio de 48 centavos es este
triangulito verde de acá por lo que es
48 centavos por unidad multiplicado por
el número total de unidades nuestro
costo es el área en este rectángulo más
pequeño por lo que las ganancias va a
ser la diferencia entre ambos
rectángulos nuestro ingreso total es el
área bajo la curva o bajo la línea
púrpura el rectángulo que tiene este
margen de ingresos y nuestra costa es el
rectángulo que tiene la línea de nuestro
costo total promedio por lo que nuestras
ganancias se van a encontrar en el área
que estoy resaltando acá la altura es la
diferencia entre nuestro costo marginal
que es el mismo que nuestro ingreso
marginal y nuestro costo total por lo
que la altura van a ser estos dos
centavos 50 menos 48 van a ser 2
centavos y esto va a ser multiplicado
por 9 mil unidades las unidades
producidas son 9000
son 9000 vamos a ganar dos centavos por
unidad
recuerden que nuestro costo total
promedio es de 48 centavos lo estamos
vendiendo a 50 centavos por unidad por
lo que ganamos 2 centavos por unidad 2
centavos por 9 mil unidades nos va a dar
a 18 centavos o 180 dólares de ganancia
ahora lo que quiero que ustedes piensen
y voy a responder a esto en el siguiente
vídeo es acaso tiene sentido tiene
sentido vender unidades entonces cuántas
unidades debemos vender si y esta es la
pregunta si el precio del mercado si el
precio del mercado es menor que su costo
total promedio tiene sentido hacer esto
y cuántas unidades deberíamos producir
si esto tuviera algún sentido digamos si
el precio del mercado fuera 48 centavos
48 centavos por unidad tendría sentido
para nosotros producir jugo de naranja